ccsd students returned to the classroom
today still concerns over cobit of
course are pretty relevant eight news
now reporter sally jadamillo live near
eastern and karen and sally some didn't
even make it into the classroom today
yeah i spoke to several students and
teachers and parents who tell me they
had mixed feelings about today amongst
their biggest concern covet 19 cases
rising but once things for sure they
sure hope they don't return to online
learning
unfortunately i didn't make it back due
to
a positive coveted test kristen niger is
a kindergarten teacher at steve shore
elementary she was looking forward to
going back to school what i do know from
what i'm hearing out in the grapevine is
that there are a ton of schools that are
missing a ton of staff and it's a
complete skeleton crew today nigro says
it's no secret coping numbers are on the
rise and so she expected the first date
to have many people calling out she
became aware through a support ccsd page
where educators communicate to one
another in our school alone i think i
counted like 13 absences today which is
like outrageous we have so many people
covering we have a counselor covering a
kindergarten position today like it's
just really crazy her biggest concern
right now students and teachers getting
sick and having to return to online
learning parent brian
of course yes uh because because for me
i i do believe the in-person class is
way better than doing it online isa
stellato middle school algebra teacher
at lead stem academy says more than ever
her students need hands-on learning we
already did the distance education so if
they were we were to switch that
tomorrow we would be prepared their
message to other teachers tonight be
real with your parents let them know you
know it's tough they know it's not a
secret
back out live one thing that did strike
teachers the number of emails received
from parents and students saying they
were in close contact with someone who
had covert for now reporting live
saliharamiyo live local now